[Music]
[Music]
hello
i'm susan goldberg the editor-in-chief
of national geographic
and editorial director of national
geographic partners
i'm pleased to welcome you to our
discussion of covid19
we'll look at the current state of the
pandemic try to forecast its future
and we'll look to the past at
life-saving lessons we can learn now
about plagues throughout human history
that's the subject of this month's cover
story
in national geographic since the
beginning of the year
this novel coronavirus has altered life
as we know it
there are of course a staggering number
of cases and a growing number of deaths
but nothing is untouched work school
family life milestones like graduations
and sadly funerals even the act of
taking a walk or going to the grocery
store
can feel surreal all of us pine for
normal
and we're not done yet under the threat
of this plague
we again look to science to save us
today we're watching in real time
as scientists work frantically to defeat
this invisible enemy
many are optimistic that a vaccine will
be available
early next year this feat whenever it
happens
will be the result of a collaboration of
many heroes
so let's dive in join us behind our
yellow border
and hear insights directly from esteemed
scientists
journalists historians and local leaders
about the effort to tackle covet 19 and
how we can stop pandemics by more deeply
understanding
how we've dealt with history's deadliest
outbreaks
we're honored today to have dr anthony
fauci the nation's top infectious
disease specialist
here in conversation with abc news
correspondent deborah roberts
who will serve as the moderator for
today's discussions
we'll also hear from richard coniff
writer of national geographic magazine's
cover story
dr jennifer ashton chief medical
correspondent for abc news
cecon akpan science editor for national
geographic
ndc's mayor muriel bowser
on behalf of everyone at national
geographic i'd like to thank you for
joining us for what's sure to be an
illuminating discussion
we hope you'll come away with new
knowledge about pandemics
and inspired by the work going on to
fight covet 19.
and with that i'll turn it over to
deborah
susan thank you it is a privilege to be
here with you today and
an honor and thank you to national
geographic for hosting this
urgent conversation you know they say
knowledge is power and we're going to
begin today with the person
most suited to make us knowledgeable
about this current
covet 19 crisis and that is the
country's top
infectious disease expert dr anthony
fauci
now of course we all know him as a
tireless and comforting figure who has
guided us through this pandemic but the
truth is he's actually been out on the
forefront
diagnosing and treating serious immune
related diseases throughout his
professional
career and he's also been a trusted
advisor
to six that's right six american
presidents
so dr fauci welcome thank you very much
it's good to be with you
well we've begun this pandemic uh with
so much
fear and now people have taken to
greeting each other by first asking
about each other's health so let me ask
you
how are you are you well
i i am well thank you deborah i i'm
quite exhausted but i have learned over
the last several months
that you know adrenaline and purpose are
pretty good energizers so
i'm actually all in all doing fine thank
you for asking
well good we appreciate that because we
certainly do need you
um let's start off by talking about
where we are in this country
um close to uh we've finally topped
sadly five million infectious uh cases
we're creeping up now slowly on 200 000
deaths
one estimate said possibly 300 000 by
the end of the year
have we even come close to peaking and
what do you make of where we
are versus where you hoped we would be
when this whole thing began for us
almost
six months ago well deborah we certainly
are not
where i hope we would be we are in the
middle
uh of a very serious historic uh
pandemic i mean the numbers speak for
themselves
i mean you have 160 000 deaths and 5
million infections in this country where
i hoped we would be
that when we had the peak that went up
in which we were hit hard particularly
in the northeastern part of the country
when the new york metropolitan area
accounted for
almost 50 percent of all the cases
hospitalizations and deaths
but then what we saw was something that
would be inevitable
if we didn't do the kinds of things that
we've been talking about intensively of
late
and that is not we did not have a
universal in the sense of everybody
pulling
in the same direction of the kinds of
things that can contain
and slow down an outbreak the things
that we've spoken about
distancing masks avoiding crowds
outdoors better than indoors washing
hands doing things like closing bars
where appropriate because that seems to
be a hot spot of transmission
so when we went up instead of coming all
the way down
to a baseline that is really uh
workable in the sense so that when you
try to open the country which
we inevitably have to do i mean we can't
just be locked down forever
because of the deleterious consequences
of that
so when we tried to open up several of
the states and we know
right now we've seen it southern states
california
florida texas arizona they came back up
so that in our baseline
instead of being way way down the way
some of the european countries were able
to attain
with a more uniform effort of keeping
everybody
on the same plane we started to have an
increase
so we went from a really very high
unacceptable baseline
of 20 000 new infections a day to 30 40
50 60
and even 70. right now
we are turning the corner in that
direction and those
states are having now less deaths less
hospitalizations less cases
but when you look at other parts of the
country this is the thing that's
disturbing to me
is that we're starting to see the
inkling of the upticks
in the percent of the tests that are
positive
which we know now from sad past
experience
that that's a predictor that you're
going to have more
surges so unless we all pull together
to get that down and we don't have
disparities in
some states are doing this and some
states are doing that
we're going to continue to have this up
and down so that's the thing that i'm
concerned about because i believe
we can we have it within our power to be
able to get that down
bottom line is i'm not pleased with how
things are going
and we do have this patchwork of
guidelines around the country some
states have opened up a little bit some
not as much
um can we even begin to get americans to
get on board if we have
essentially regions of the country that
are operating in very different ways i
mean how how do we actually
get a unified um uh
response to this if we're not we have
states that are acting
all very differently well you know
that is a simple question deborah but
the answer is complicated because of the
great
divergence of opinions throughout the
country and the
independence as it were of the states
and local areas
of the kinds of decisions that they want
to make i had said
over and over again and that's the
reason why i welcome a dialogue with you
deborah to get the message across
that there are five or six things that
if
everyone at a minimum did that
we know from history of other countries
we know from what we've seen in our own
country that if you do that
you can turn around the surges and
prevent further surges
and there are the things we keep talking
about i mean it's not that difficult
of the universal wearing of masks the
social distancing the avoiding crowds
the outdoors
favoring things that you do outdoors
versus indoors
washing hands etc the issue is
that because of the divisiveness that
we've seen
in this country we having i think
may be understandable because of the
differences
but unfortunately divergence where
people say either
lock down completely or let it rip have
crowds go to bars
that shouldn't be that way there is a
golden mean in there
based on the guidelines that we
carefully put together
about how you can open the country
safely
some people think that public health
measures are kind of the
obstacle to opening up they're not
they're a gateway and a vehicle to
safely
opening up because if you follow the
guidelines
the checkpoints you know you start off
by saying
you've got to get past one checkpoint if
you do well
you carefully move to the other that's a
phase you go to the next phase and the
next phase
if you do that properly and carefully
and prudently you won't see these surges
but yet understandably and this is i
guess the nature of this
illness the nature of this infection is
quite unique
i mean you mentioned in the introduction
that i have been involved in
multiple outbreaks going back four
decades from hiv aids to ebola to
pandemic flu
to zika all kinds of different
approaches
this is one of i mean the only one i've
seen
where the range of impact on people
is so extraordinarily varied you have 40
percent or so of individuals
who have no symptoms at all so when
young people particularly because
there's no doubt about it
that statistically young people do much
much better from the standpoint
of any bad outcome than elderly
individuals and those with underlying
conditions
however we're starting to see more and
more that young people
even otherwise well young people can get
into serious trouble and even may have
some long-term
residual effects but but accepting the
data
that young people generally do well
there's an understandable and i guess
somewhat innocent
uh determination that if i
as i'm not but if i were a young person
and i got infected i look around at my
friends they say you know the
overwhelming majority of them
do just fine so what's the difference if
i get infected
i'm in a vacuum i'm not hurting anybody
that's incorrect
because you are inadvertently and
innocently
propagating an outbreak that is killing
some people
so even though you think you're doing
fine and you're not
deliberately trying to hurt anybody the
fact that you've been
careless and not looked at the
guidelines that you don't want to wear a
mask
that you want to be in a crowd you get
infected and what happens
is that almost certainly you or your
friends and colleagues will infect
someone else who will infect someone
else
and then someone is going to get
seriously ill and maybe die that could
be someone's mother their father
an even a depressed child any of those
individuals who are susceptible
so you've got to appreciate and i know
it's tough to get your
feel about that but you've got to
appreciate that not only do you have
an individual responsibility to yourself
you have a societal responsibility to
help us
all get this outbreak under control
because when it is under control then
you could start doing
with much less difficulty the things
that you really want to do
we could start to open the economy
safely we can get the jobs back
we can do all those things but the
nature of our country
of people having this independent
feeling like i don't want to do this
because someone is telling me to do it i
guess that's understandable
and that independence is part of the
core of our country
you know we don't we you know we like
authority but we don't like authority
um that's getting us into trouble and
that's what i think the complexity
of all of this is founded in that that
inconsistency
of what we're doing someone said the
other day
while the coronavirus isn't over people
seem to be over the coronavirus
let's talk about some of these images
that we have seen
pictures of people around the country in
large locations
at bars on beaches without masks
many people seem to just have an
aversion to wearing masks even though
you and other experts have said that
this is
key i read some statistics that said we
could possibly save
up to 70 000 lives by wearing masks
how do you get some skeptical
people in this country to really
understand the importance of wearing
masks and
how long do you think we're going to be
wearing them for
well you know i can't predict deborah
how long it'll be
i know that right now if you look at the
numbers
they don't lie you can't run away from
the numbers you can't run away
from the numbers of people who've died
the number of people are getting
hospitalized the surges
we're seeing it's going to depend on us
you know you're asking me a very valid
question how long we're going to have to
be doing this
depends totally on us if we keep running
away from the reality of the need
to do it it could linger on and linger
on
you know you hear people talk about well
you'll get hurt immunity
so why don't we you know let's just get
a lot of people infected and then
we'll be protected if you do that
that is probably true but a lot of
people are going to die if you do that
so i think as a society the ingrained
in our human spirit we don't want to
really see that because already
more than 160 000 people in this country
have died do we really want to see a lot
more die
i don't think so i think the other
alternative
is to contain it to the extent that we
can until we get the interventions which
are on their way
interventions like good treatments
interventions hopefully
although there's no real guarantee but
hopefully that we will have a vaccine
one or more because there are multiple
candidates
out there one or more vaccines by the
end of this year the beginning
of 2021 so this is going to end so the
idea of
you know if it's going to go on and on
let's just get it over with no
we can be part of the solution
as opposed to passively saying just let
it happen
i don't find that to be acceptable we
can do
things without necessarily stopping
all the things that are important we
can't open the economy
we can get jobs back at the same time
as still practicing good public health
measures
let's talk about vaccines russia has
said this week that it has actually come
out with a vaccine now that it's going
to start
actually um inoculating uh people with
this
what do you think about that do you
think they've actually got this vaccine
and how close are we in this country to
really having something and how do we
begin to dispense it
well i mean having a vaccine deborah and
proving
that a vaccine is safe and effective
are two different things we have half a
dozen
or more vaccines so if we wanted to take
the chance of
hurting a lot of people or giving them
something that doesn't work
we could start doing this you know next
week if we wanted to but
that's not the way it works so i hope
but i haven't heard
any evidence to make me feel that's the
case i hope that the russians
have actually definitively proven that
the vaccine is safe and effective
i seriously doubt that they've done that
but that's what i think people need to
understand when they hear announcements
from the chinese or from the russians
that we have a vaccine
we're giving a vaccine and people say
why aren't the americans doing that
well because we have a way of doing
things in this country that we care
about safety
and we care about efficacy
how do we actually how do you anticipate
this will play out once
we do get what we think will be a viable
vaccine who will get it how quickly will
it be out there to the public and will
that put an end to
what we're dealing with with covet 19
well it depends on how effective it is
you know the vaccine statistical
framework of it
is to try and show that we have at least
a 50 percent
effective vaccine i i would hope and it
could possibly be as high as 60 70 75
that's what i'm hoping for uh you know
vaccines
uh against respiratory diseases like
this generally
generally are not going to be as as high
i mean we know that from influenza as
high
as what we say with measles like measles
is 97
to 98 effective i would hope
that we could get that way i don't think
that's going to be the case i would
gladly accept a 55 50
to 75 effective vaccine that would mean
not that you could throw caution to the
wind
and do nothing else but get vaccinated
that means the vaccine would be
very very helpful and a very important
additional tool additional to public
health measures
to get us out of this pandemic and back
to a normal existence
so as i've said many times i'm
cautiously optimistic that we will
have that now your question about who
gets it
well you know we have a standard way
that have been done over
decades of when you have a scarce
intervention
particularly in the first months of
distributing a vaccine as you're gearing
up
to get more and more doses ultimately
arrangements have been made
to have enough vaccine for everybody in
this country but in the beginning as we
start to roll it out
what you do is you have advisory
committees the typical one
is the advisory committee on
immunization practices
which advises the cdc who traditionally
have had the task of making that
determination of prioritization
according to recommendations this time
we're going to add an additional layer
of that
to complement that and the nih and the
cdc have got together
to commission the national academy of
medicine to bring together an
independent group
of ethicists biologists vaccinologists
community people
to to look at the prioritization and to
make a prioritization
we don't know what that's going to be
but likely if it follows the path
of other prioritizations it'll be things
like having people who are health care
providers and front line
emergency responders because they every
day put themselves at risk
as well as individuals who are more
vulnerable to serious consequences such
as
the elderly and people with underlying
conditions those are the kind of things
that
generally are prioritized but will leave
that ultimate decision to the committee
and to the cdc
i know you're a very busy man but there
are two topics that we need to get to
there are things that are top of mind
for people right now for parents
top of mind right now is their kids
going back to school
you have said that you would like to see
of course
kids going back to school because they
benefit from having this normal routine
but can we safely send kids back to
school right now
almost a hundred thousand children just
in the last few weeks being infected
with the coronavirus
we've seen incidents in schools in
georgia and mississippi where they've
seen an uptick in children who have gone
back to school who've now
contracted the virus can we safely send
our kids back to school
in person at this moment that's a great
question
debra and the answer is as as i think
you've introduced it correctly
i believe as a default position we
should try
as best as we possibly can to get the
children back to school for all the
reasons that you mentioned the benefits
for the children
the unintended negative consequences if
we don't but there's a big however there
and the how however is or the but
is that we make sure that the primary
consideration
is the safety the health and the welfare
of the children
as well as their teachers and the
secondary effects of people they may
come into contact with
what i really mean is that we live in a
big country
and there are areas and regions of the
country the green zones as we call them
where the level of infection is low
enough that you really should try very
hard
to get the children back to school and
there should be no reason not to do that
there are also areas which we generally
refer to as the yellow zone
where there are levels of infection that
to get the children back you should
carefully follow
the cdc guidelines everyone should be
following the cdc guidelines
but looking at things that you can
mitigate the likelihood
that they're going to get infected and
to know what to do if in fact you get an
infected child
but you can probably get children back
to school by doing things like modifying
school schedules
maybe some outdoor classes wearing masks
important
wearing masks as i said before and doing
things like a
possibly more physical separation
hybrid schedules a lot of things but
finally
importantly when you have a situation
where you're in a red hot zone where you
have a lot of infection going on
i think you've really got to use
judgment and carefully consider
do you really want to put the kids back
in school under those circumstances
and i think many parents and teachers
are going to vote with their feet
on that so again big country it's not
going to be unidimensional
it's not going to be one size fits all
but we've got to be sensitive
to the safety and the welfare of the
children and the teachers
we've seen these uh almost comical
images of kids
dressed from head to toe in hazmat suits
uh to go back to school
do they need to be masked when they go
back to school wherever they are
yeah i think that depends on again the
level
and the age i mean the level of
infection if you're in an area
where there is active community
transmission
i would recommend strongly that if the
children are old enough to be able to
keep a mask on
that you put masks on children
what about voting so many people are
concerned we're in an election year
some people are going to be heading to
the polls in the next few weeks can
people
safely go out and vote in person given
that this year there is so much
uh concern around the vote
i think if carefully done according to
the guidelines
there's no reason that i can see why
that not be the case
for example you know when you look at
going to a grocery store now in many
regions and counties and cities that are
doing it correctly
they have x's every six or more feet
and it says don't leave this spot until
the person in front of you
left their spot and you can do that if
you go and wear a mask
if you observe the physical distancing
and don't have a crowded situation
there's no reason
why you shouldn't be able to do that i
mean obviously
if your person who is compromised
physically or otherwise you don't want
to take the chance
there's the situation of mail-in voting
that is done
for years in many places so there's no
reason why
we shouldn't be able to vote in person
or otherwise
there is a lot of concern about this
fall in this winter whether we're going
to see an uptick
again in the corona virus the novel
coronavirus
look into your crystal ball if you would
for me uh
a year from now where do you think we
will be will we have this thing under
control or will we still be social
distancing and wearing masks
well that's going to depend on two
things that's going to depend on the
success
of vaccines and like i said although i'm
cautiously optimistic i've been doing
this long enough
to never ever guarantee success when
you're dealing with vaccines but i think
we would have a vaccine so if you're
talking about this time next year
and we have a vaccine and we get the
level of
infection so low that we can
successfully contain any little blips
that occur
and prevent those blips from becoming
surges the way we have seen
and are seeing in certain states i think
that we could be in a really good place
this time next year but a lot of it is
going to be up to us
as citizens to uniformly
adhere to public health principles at
the same time
that we're fortunate enough to have good
therapies
and a vaccine that's effective if we do
we will be in a good place by this time
next year
dr fauci your leadership has not come
without uh some stresses and
frustrations
personally you have talked about during
the aids crisis how you
got hate mail and during this crisis you
have had
death threats to the point that you've
had to hire security
we saw such unity in the very beginning
of this pandemic people
saying that we're all in this together
now we're seeing a lot of anger
did you see that coming and where does
that come from yeah
well i just think it's it's a reflection
of the divisiveness in the country
it has taken on a political tone uh
like nothing i've ever seen i mean i've
gotten people
who are upset that i was putting effort
on
hiv aids i mean a lot of that was people
who were homophobic
uh and felt i was diverting resources to
people that they didn't think
should be part of society obviously
ridiculous
but that was never anything that was
serious the way it is now
where people get angry enough that they
threaten my life and
terribly harass my wife and my children
with phone calls and
i don't even want to talk about the
things that they do which you know led i
didn't hire security the federal
government is
is providing it for me it seems
inconceivable
i mean if you just think about it take a
deep breath and think about it
that when you're trying to promote
public health principles
to save people's lives and keep them
healthy
that there's such divisiveness in the
country that that's interpreted
to be so far from your own way of
thinking
that you actually want to threaten the
person i mean i just
it's tough for me to figure that out
except to say
boy i hope we get past
this divisiveness in our country and get
more down to
even though people have their different
thoughts and different ideologies
that we get it out of the realm of such
intense
divisiveness that you start doing things
like threatening people that that's just
no way that our society
can really function well and go along
that way we've got to get past that
well you have been out there out front
you have been tireless in all of your
work
i'm wondering when you look back if you
had it to do over again would you throw
that same pitch
at the nationals game
well you know i got to tell you the
the monitor with the story is don't
practice so much that you throw your arm
out
i should have just got up and just said
okay i haven't thrown it i haven't
thrown a baseball in so many years let
me just throw it
it was it was a little embarrassing but
it was actually kind of funny uh deborah
it was got you kind of funny it was fun
it was fun to see you and my husband put
me up to that i have to tell you
well dr fauci on behalf of myself and
national geographic we just thank you
for all that you have done and continue
to do
to try to keep our communities safe and
we just wish you the best and of course
wish us all the best
as we try to fight through this novel
corona virus it was a pleasure to talk
with you and a pleasure to have you here
today
thank you very much deborah i really
appreciate you giving me the opportunity
to be with you thanks
now i'm privileged to be joined by a
distinguished group of panelists
including washington d.c mayor muriel
bowser
abc chief medical correspondent dr
jennifer ashton
national geographic science editor c
khan akpan
and author of the national geographic
magazine august cover story
richard conniff welcome to all of you
it's so great to get a chance to see you
dr ashton i'm going to begin with you um
i'm going to uh
invoke the powers of nepotism since
we're in the same family abc
family um i want to start off with you
talking about
russia's claims that it has a vaccine
they claim that uh they are the first
ones to actually get a
viable vaccine uh putin says his
daughter has taken it
what do you think the chances are that
this is an actual viable vaccine against
the
novel coronavirus well i think it's
definitely the
shot heard around the world in terms of
vaccine news right now
i think we have to remember that in
science and medicine
a healthy amount of cynicism and
skepticism
is generally a good idea when something
sounds too good to be true
in medicine it usually is however
we do have unprecedented global
collaboration for the development
of a sars kovi ii vaccine with a lot of
developers
um doing really well and making good
progress here come the caveats
uh as far as we know at this time
russia has not completed or even really
started comprehensive phase three trials
yet which usually
involve the recruitment of tens of
thousands of volunteers
and then we need to wait and see not
just short-term but long-term
safety and efficacy um and
you know until we see that in the
scientific community
worldwide there will be plenty of people
my feeling is more rather than less who
are very very cynical about this
you echoed the sentiments of dr fauci
who says he's sort of worried about
whether this is
actually a clinically tried vaccine but
yet we do
have some that are in various phases of
clinical trials
what's your guess about how soon we can
actually hope for a vaccine in this
country
well first of all in medicine and
science history and
past experience absolutely helps to
inform
our assessment uh or forecast about what
could go on in the future and just for
some historical context and perspective
deb
uh the fastest ever vaccine that has
been developed
in history took four years so
if we have dosable vaccine in
any amount whether it's a million doses
or tens of millions of doses or
eventually
hundreds of millions of doses any time
before then
that will be a land speed record um you
know
cautious optimism is the term that we've
heard from the beginning
dr fauci says that all the time you've
heard him say that
uh he said that in conversations with me
and i think it's important to remember
that it's unlikely that there will be
just one vaccine there are different
types of
methods and mechanisms being
investigated right now and
several at least three are in phase
three clinical trials so
again it takes a certain amount of time
and you cannot cut
corners when you're talking about
long-term efficacy
and safety the the timeline is still the
timeline
as much as we may want it richard let me
turn to you
um if i can you have written extensively
about the history of pandemics including
um the august issue of the national
geographic cover story
and let's talk about where we are at
this point in time and sort of contrast
it
uh 800 000 deaths worldwide we're
creeping up or we've actually surpassed
in this country now
5 million coronavirus cases creeping up
to close to
200 000 deaths in this country
you talked uh very in a very detailed
way in your article about
the smallpox pandemic for instance and
just how
um how devastating and debilitating this
could be but also
trying to contrast where we are now
versus where we were then
similarities in the public reaction uh
what have you learned
in your research about what we can learn
from history and also maybe what we
don't seem to learn from history
so the big thing for me is that
all of us who have been born since world
war ii
have spent our lives in above um
largely without infectious diseases and
certainly without pandemics
um and for me this is personal because
well
world war ii after that the antibiotics
came in and eliminated
infectious diseases but also you had
this incredible
um outburst of vaccines which continues
to the present day
but it started in 1955 with the polio
vaccine and
i was among the first people to get that
vaccine as a
grade schooler and um on the other hand
you know
measles was epidemic when i was a kid i
i was part of the
worst epidemic year for that disease
1958
there were 700 000 cases and 550 kids
died
and the important thing to remember is
that that kind of dying that kind of
sickness
was really repeating
up until our time and so
we need to recognize um what we've
come through what we've what we've got
and and and also what we've gotten away
from
but i guess the thing that that is worth
noting about that
is that because we're free from these
diseases we tend to
forget the uh the consequences we forget
the diseases i mean even
most doctors today have never seen
diphtheria
um which was still killing 400 people a
year 400 children
uh when i was a child most people don't
even know what gift area
is um but it was called the strangling
angel back then
and it would it would create this
leathery kind of
membrane that would bridge a child's
throat and strangle a child
and it was highly infectious and it
spread within a family
from one child to another and at one
point i visited a cemetery in lancaster
massachusetts and there were six or
seven
gravestones and they were kind of
leaning together like a family
and they were a family they were the
bodies of
nine children in the morris family
five of them died within 11 days from
ditheria
one more died later that that summer and
then
three more died a few years later and it
was not uncommon
for families to lose all of their
children so
uh you know because we forget um
we have allowed our public health
structure to deteriorate
and um we you know we
have repeated warning pandemics
but because because it hasn't happened
to us in our lifetimes we've we've um
disregarded that and we've actually
dismantled
um public health services so there was
something called predict which was
an agency that was um
designed to detect and prevent epidemic
diseases and it went out of business in
october last year
about a month before the first orbit
cases appeared
we had sort of an attitude of unity in
this country uh early on in this
pandemic that we're all in it together
now there seems to be an attitude at
least amongst some people
of anger um you know ignoring the
guidelines and the protocols not wanting
to wear
um masks see khan i'd love to get your
thoughts on that
the idea that people were really
following the rules in the very
beginning and now you do
see pictures of large gatherings and
people not wearing masks and dr fauci
has talked about
his deep concerns about the fact that
we've got sort of a hodgepodge of
guidelines around the country
and that that's not helping us at all in
terms of trying to defeat this virus
yeah i think it's a couple of things i
think for one you know people are
struggling with empathy you know it's
hard to
you know visualize how this virus
is so devastating unless it happens to
you unless it happens to somebody in
your family
and i think for that reason you know
some people are having a hard time
saying
you know why should i adhere to six
months of lockdowns
you know why should i social distance
when i want to be near my friends why
should i wear this mask when
you know it's it's it's preventing me
from being able to breathe normally and
i'm not able to see my friends faces
but um i think we are seeing that this
this pandemic is devastating right we're
seeing massive amounts of deaths i think
we're
up to 160 000 deaths in the us alone
um as of today or as of this week
i think the other issue you you bring it
up this this patchwork
right the the coronavirus response 1000.
160 000. yeah excuse me um
i think the other issue is is this
patchwork of
of our response right this idea that the
the u.s response wasn't very unified we
haven't gotten
the the leadership that we might want
from for a pandemic like this in terms
of the response
and so you see all 50 states sort of
doing their own things and then even on
a more micro level you see
you know some counties doing different
things and i think when that happens it
becomes very hard to
to test trace isolate which is which are
things that we need to do
and also to get people to adhere to
social distancing when there's when
there's
hearing mixed messages it's going to be
harder for them to
to trust the public health guidelines
that they're they're hearing and also
to want to follow them even if they
really want to follow them because they
won't know what to do
well mayor bowser that's a perfect
opening to you because
you know regions mayors governors are
having to sort of set the standards in
their communities
uh how do you what what guidelines do
you
adhere to i mean of course we've heard
the cdc issue guidelines we've heard dr
fauci talk
about his concerns um where do you go
for the guidance and and how are you
handling
the masks and the the uh protocols
in dc when sometimes you do run up
against people who don't necessarily
want to follow
those rules uh well thanks for that
question deborah and certainly
um i think it's unfortunate that we have
a patchwork
of of guidance across our country i
think that we've seen globally that
countries that have acted in a unified
way have been able not only to blunt the
curve
but to contain transmission
of the virus and i think it was pretty
clear to all of us at the outset that
that was the
only way to get back to normal um the
fastest
um so what we're left with is um this
kind of idea that governors
would solve the problem now we're in
washington dc uh i'm the
mayor county executive governor and i
don't have two senators but that's
another matter
um and so we are left to to look to the
the science and kind of act on our own
um
and realizing that our borders are
porous
act within our region the metropolitan
washington region so we continue to do
that
we have an excellent health staff
that's guided by science that stays
connected with the other health
directors in the region and the cdc
to follow the the best advice that we
have
now i will say i think everybody
recognizes that
the guidance that we started with at the
beginning of this pandemic has evolved
over time and we have had uh to
evolve with it and um
what we continue to call on though i
don't think it's too late and we have to
all be focused on calling our
federal officials to the table is not
too late to have a federal plan
to do a better job at testing and
supplies
in national guidance whether it's mass
or travel advisories or
um some guidance on testing like when
should people get tested that would that
make better use
of our testing infrastructure and only
when we're able to do that
up until we get a vaccine do i think
we'll will get
some rational policies moving forward
and in the meantime you're having to use
your judgment right now during a period
that
is very difficult for parents and that
is going for their kids to go back to
school
um yes there is a patchwork of uh
decision there are patchworks of
decisions all around the country right
now
some school districts the los angeles uh
school district is
going to remain online the new york city
schools one of the largest in the
country is going to
gradually open their doors you're
cautious about that though in your
district
what are you going to do and how did you
make that decision uh
it's probably one of the most difficult
decisions in all of this
because i for one know that online
school is no replacement for school
kids being able to learn with their
colleagues their
classmates and be in front of teachers
we know that teachers make all the
difference
in education and so
what we're doing at home is no
replacement for
school and we have some
tough decisions to make around what the
health data tell us
um but then you mix into that um
all of our workforce requirements and
our workforce wanting to come back
as well as parents and parental
confidence
so it's not just me saying this is what
the health data
show um it's also saying that we have
workforce confidence and parent
confidence and then and only then
um will in-person school work for us
um taking into account all of those
things
we decided to go online
for the first term dr jen ashton let me
ask you about schools dr falchi has said
notably that um he thinks it's a good
idea for us to start trying to open the
schools again particularly in places
where the numbers are low and to sort of
go
slowly but we also know that you know
there are a number of children
over the last um a few weeks you know
we've seen what a hundred thousand
children testing a positive for the
coronavirus
um high schools in georgia mississippi
uh
children have tested positive in indiana
in one high school they actually had to
go back online for a while
what do we know about children and their
ability to transmit
and how how how worry do you think
parents really
how cautious should they be well deb i
think first
we have to start with what is known what
the available data and
and peer review evidence has shown us
and that is
evolving day-to-day like so much of what
we know about this virus
just about seven months into uh our
relationship with it
what it appears right now is that the
pediatric
age group does get infected they
do transmit the virus how much they
transmit or spread it to others is still
unknown but they appear to be
less likely to get severely ill
now a lower risk does not mean zero risk
and that's a very important distinction
this is a unique
population but as we segue from
the medical and scientific to the more
societal and social and emotional
aspects of this decision deb and why it
is so
emotionally charged and complex
complicated
is that when you talk about numbers like
those that the american academy of
pediatrics just released about the
number of confirmed cases
understand that those statistics
represent real children and as we know
as
parents um that is a completely
different you know rule set than when we
talk about adults even and so
our tolerance for risk as individuals
may be very different than how much risk
and uncertainty and fear we're willing
to accept and tolerate when it comes to
our children
and that by the way goes also to the
part of superintendents and educators
and
and governors and mayors and politicians
who also have to weigh in on this
decision
uh so it is complicated dr fauci
has said multiple times this is not a
one-size-fits-all equation
it's one that will need to have the
flexibility
um to be able to pivot and adapt and
respond to changes in real time
i don't think we should be surprised
when we hear of
cases it's more how many cases over what
period of time and how we
will respond to those cases and we also
have to think of the ripple effect here
it's not just the children but it's
the households in which they live it's
the faculty and
students and about a whole big one
that's right and and it's now um been
been recently reported that a quarter of
school
teachers live with a pre-existing or
underlying medical condition that may
put
them at increased risk um and so there's
a saying in emergency
medicine services is the scene safe you
do not go in to rescue someone else
unless the scene is safe for you and
we don't know yet across the board
whether this scene is safe but it's also
important to remember to bring it back
to the medical
there is no such thing as zero risk uh
children
can and do die every year of influenza
they die of meningitis
so this is not only about this virus
it's just that that is getting the
lion's share of attention with good
reason at this time
and there also even amongst these
studies there are kind of conflicting
reports i mean there is
one study that says latino children are
eight times more likely to be
hospitalized black children five times
more likely to be hospitalized than say
their white peers
so then you have other concerns too out
there amongst the school population and
for those parents there are differences
within the specific demographic
population deb and there's also
differences
just in the educational population there
are children with disabilities children
with special needs
that are also a specialized unique group
that need to be considered here they've
gotten almost no attention
publicly and in the media on this issue
and so
this is an absolutely complex
decision that cannot be made with the
flip of a switch
we just don't have all the right
information at this point and we don't
have
the testing capability right now to be
able to
mitigate the risk in cases or cities
where they are seeing
incredibly high rates and i've heard you
on multiple occasions say as
doctors you know there's no harm in
saying we don't know because this this
virus is evolving
richard let me ask you we've been
talking about the patchwork
of guidelines around the country we have
some states that are
almost fully open some states that are
beginning to open some that have
actually started to close back up again
because they've seen a spike
in the number of cases so you know when
we look historically
at trying to defeat a pandemic how
difficult is it when you don't have
a national policy and you have this
patchwork of guidelines and
you know one state doing one thing in
another state doing another and also the
the american psyche maybe not even
taking this in in the way
that it could right very individualistic
and
and that's that's sort of a difficult
thing it may be more easy
in a culture that is more
society-oriented
um but actually what worked best i i
hate to say it in the past
to get unified action was a horrifying
epidemic so cholera and london
in the 1840s um it suddenly provoked
people to take pollution
water pollution and contaminated water
lines seriously
and the city then invested heavily in
building and
um and london then became the example
for the world for the united states
particularly and
and elsewhere um that you had to take
this stuff
seriously if you want to prevent disease
i think what we need to do now and you
know i saw an associated report
associated press report yesterday that
um
since 2008 we have lost 38 000
state and local public health jobs
people people resigning under pressure
um because people have not taken
pandemic seriously
um and we need to fix that so
there's a saying that you know it's
better to have a fire department
um already built than to try to fling it
together when your house is already
burning down
uh well we need that fire department and
um
that that means not just doing it on the
national
or the state local level and the
national level but it also means
investing in public health
internationally so in the course of the
story for national geographic i met this
great character
named michael callahan was a kind of
selling of infectious disease
wherever there's been an outbreak really
the horse diseases from ebola on
over the past 20 years he has been there
with these other
what he described as high energy
compressed speech people
and um and he said that the things that
work
they're not necessarily dramatic so he
said helping other countries
meet their public health needs even
countries that aren't necessarily
friendly to us
um really works well so in indonesia in
about 2005
there was an outbreak of of an avian flu
and indonesia really depended on its
poultry
trade because its fisheries have been
destroyed and and it's a muslim country
so they don't need pork
so his group he worked for darpa at that
point the
defense department's advanced research
branch and they went in there and they
equipped
indonesian physicians with gene
sequencing and they
worked hard to to upgrade so that they
were independent of the west independent
of the united states
um and that got them from veterinary
disease monitoring into human disease
monitoring
and you have to have that kind of
capacity to kind of access
in in these countries all over the world
because that's where emerging diseases
emerge and he said one other thing that
it's important to build
lifelong relationships
starting with young doctors who are
working on infectious disease
and build their careers and put their
names on
on articles and scholarly journal type
yours um bring
them to us schools and to improve their
education
and and build them up in their country
so that then
they feel like you're a trusted ally and
in one case he did that with
a um with researchers who had in the
soviet union been working on chemical
weapons
and they switched over to um working on
public health and infectious disease
and one result of that was that um that
h1n1 avian flu that was coming i think
was 2005
it was coming up through siberia and
these guys alerted the united states so
that public health workers could go to
alaska
spring um the migrating birds coming up
the
western side of the pacific and across
and make sure that that
pandemic did not that that that disease
did not get into this continent and
because it can not only destroy
you know wildlife and and then indian
and poultry but also it can kill young
people by destroying their lungs
but of course it the the will of the
people to actually
listen to follow science mayor bowser
we know that uh dr fauci and all the
other experts
infectious disease experts continue to
tout mask wearing social distancing
of course hand washing all of those
great
um recommendations for staying safe but
the mask wearing has become an issue in
a lot of
regions of the country where does dc
come down with west mass wearing at the
moment because some places have actually
mandatorily required them some places
have made them optional
where do you come down on masks and how
do you enforce it
um we have a pretty
far-reaching mask order basically what
we've recommended to our residents is
when they leave the house to wear a mask
specifically the mayor's order says that
if you can't
socially distance then you should
uh have on a mask enforcement
is a is a tricky thing you know there's
700 000 people who live in the district
if they all decided that they wouldn't
comply
um then it would be unenforceable um but
largely i would say
our residents and business owners uh
have the ethos that we're going to
protect each other
and stand with each other so our mask
ordinance by and large
uh is um is being followed now there are
some notable
exceptions and we struggle
with making sure that our enforcement
which
could be enforced by the police and with
a fine
is proportionate uh to
the problem that officials encounter but
the bottom line is it is going to have
to be
if we're going we want uh large
compliance with mass squaring
sending the signals from the top and
doing it consistently across the united
states of america is the most important
thing we can do
what worries you most right now as we
try to get a handle on this virus and we
continue to see
the numbers ticking up there is one
estimate that we may see 300 000 deaths
by the end of the year
as dr ashton said we don't know about a
vaccine yet and whether we're going to
actually have a viable one by the end of
the year
as a leader what what worries you the
most at this moment
um certainly we're worried about um
health and getting control of the virus
but what this
virus and the shutdowns have done to
[ __ ]
our economies is
i don't even know if we can fully
appreciate it
i can go to parts of down downtown dc
that
are totally closed um people don't know
when they're going to report back to
their offices we're not sure when kids
are going to go back
to school restaurants and small
businesses shuttering
we don't know if people are going to
have the unemployment assistance that
they need
already millions of people aren't paying
their rent
and what is that going to mean for
affordable housing
production so bringing our economy back
is a huge part of what we all have to be
focused on
on in our country people who have done
nothing wrong um don't know how they're
going to put food on the table
or don't know how they're going to pay
rent landlords
who have done nothing wrong also
don't know how they're going to make
mortgage payments and continue to be
able to provide affordable housing
so i think we all have to be focused on
people who've lost everything in this
pandemic
and how as a country no local government
no state government is going to be able
to fill that gap
so how are we as a country i'm going to
be
able to make sure um that those
of us americans who've been impacted by
this virus can survive
economically and as we go forward
there's been some talk about herd
immunity
what in your reporting have you learned
about how we as a
as a group begin to try to recover from
this in
in that way and that we can actually
feel safe eventually
even though we may still have this virus
amongst us
yeah i mean i think the first thing to
say about herd immunity is that
if we want to achieve it we really need
a vaccine i think
trying to achieve herd immunity through
natural infection
um would be devastating i think you
would have
you know much more death than we've had
now and you'd have you know way more
people
with you know these chronic long hauler
conditions that we're starting to see so
really if we
if we want to get to herd immunity we
need a vaccine
um based on some statistical analyses
it's thought that we probably need about
60 to 70 percent of the population to be
uh vaccinated in order to reach herd
immunity
um it could be up to 80 or 90 percent
can you explain for those who don't know
what herd immunity really is
yeah absolutely so herd immunity is the
idea that if enough people in a
community or a population
are immune to a disease um it'll break
the transmission chains it'll break the
ability of the virus to spread from
person to person
so for measles you know herd immunity
for the measles
vaccine herd immunity is about 80 to 90
percent
um for months i believe it's about 70 to
80 percent
um we don't know what that benchmark is
yet for coronavirus and it'll probably
take some time
to to figure it out but if we really
want to get this
disease under control we will likely
need herd immunity if we really want to
go back to the way things were we will
likely need
herd immunity until then we really need
people to follow the public health
guidance that's being recommended by our
top experts like dr fauci
because it is possible to break the
chains of transmission just through
social distancing
through mass squaring you know through
walking
through locking down sort of some
high-risk activities
i mean that's what we've seen in south
korea that's what we've seen in new
zealand that's what we've seen in
germany that's what we've seen
to some degree in dc i think dc has been
pretty good about
being able to bring its its caseloads
down to a situation where we are
in phase two right now where we are able
to to to dine out to some degree in
restaurants and
have some semblance of of normalcy
returned i was just gonna dovetail on
something
that um that mayor bowser said before
because
as she talked about the economic and
social
ripple effects of this pandemic and this
virus
i think that's a really good metaphor
for how we also
have to think medically and how i know
every mayor
and and governor is thinking which is
it's not
just about the virus that's a concern
right now
understand that just medically people
don't stop having heart attacks or
strokes or car accidents
or developing appendicitis just because
we're
in the middle of a pandemic so if our
hospitals are under water and they're
at or over capacity and you have
a heart attack or chest pain and you
can't get the proper medical care you
need
because everyone is focused on treating
covid patients
that literally affects everyone so in
medicine you always have to remember to
take a holistic or 360 degree view
however you want to look at it look at
the
whole organism and body not just a body
part or a disease and understand
that the ripple effects of this virus
medically economically
socially politically educationally are
massive and it's a lot more than just
the case count or the test positivity
rate or
unfortunately the death count it's
something that has
the absolute potential to affect
every single person in this country
whether they get
infected with covid or not so as a
physician
that's what we look at that's what
public health officials are concerned
with that's what politicians
and leaders are concerned with as well
and that's what i think concerns a lot
of people too because at the
at the um it still time still marches on
and now here we are approaching labor
day the typical
time when people are going back to work
and back to school we have an election
coming up
dr jen speak to voting if you would
because there are a lot of people who
are worried about uh
going out is it safe for them to
actually think about going out to the
polls to
exercise their right to vote um we've
seen all of these
um almost comical um drawings of people
in hazmat suits from top to bottom going
you know
kids going to school other people going
other places is it safe for people to
start thinking about resuming some of
these things in the midst of this
pandemic at this moment particularly
going out to vote
well the question you ask is really how
do
we stratify risk and
uh some doctors don't do that very well
let's be clear
um so it can be incredibly challenging
and daunting
for a lay person to do that so um you
know
i have a saying that i use all the time
on the air and in my real practice which
is i would much rather teach
someone how to think like a doctor than
teach them a fact
that today we might think is accurate
and tomorrow we might learn something
new
and learn that it's out of date or
inaccurate so
how to think like a doctor when it comes
to weighing
risk is ask yourself
four questions not two questions not is
something safe yes or no
that's two questions the four questions
are what is the risk of my doing this
what is the risk of not doing it what's
the benefit of doing it
and what's the benefit of not doing it
so
everyone will have to answer those
questions for herself for himself
again it's not a one-size-fits-all uh
discussion
or thought process but when you talk
about
you know is it safe to go out and vote
it depends are you
a person who's over 70 years old who's
black or brown skin with obesity and
diabetes
living or voting in a hot spot maybe you
would say
no that's that risk is unacceptably high
when compared to the risk of staying
home but then this is complicated by
what are the benefits of doing it so
it's those four questions that people
should be in the habit of
asking when it comes to any question
in medicine um in this case in life
because you can usually make a box
put your four answers in list form in
that box
and get a pretty good idea of whether
you should or
should not do something richard do we
just have to accept the fact that we are
going to be living with this virus for a
long time and we have to sort of sort
out the risks and the benefits and
and how we go forward just in life i
mean when you look historically
um these pandemics did not you know go
away quickly
uh they they they lasted for a long
period of time so do we just have to
accept that we have to just
deal with the novel coronavirus for
quite a while and
and make peace with that in the past
certainly people did
um tuberculosis killed one in seven
people in the 19th century and
people just expected that they even
romanticized the birth relationship
it was a little weird um so yeah we
we might well be stuck with this and we
might also face
um other emerging diseases that we don't
even
begin to suspect right now and i think
that you know
rather than resignation the answer is to
start spending what we should have been
spending all long
public health and it will be expensive
and it will be expensive at a time when
our economy is
in bad shape um and yet
it's way cheaper than allowing them
we have so far national and world
governments have spent eight
trillion dollars on
kovid and we really do not want that to
happen
we want to get past this one and we do
not want to happen like that again
and dr ashton going into the fall and
the winter we know that we expect
flu and colds and all of that and then
maybe possibly another spike in
covet 19. what's your best thing
all of us all of us on this panel are
going to be
following that and have an eye on that
for sure sometimes there are unexpected
silver linings even in
the grimaced um public health global
pandemic scenarios and one of them that
that we are
in some ways almost keeping our fingers
crossed for is that all of these
aggressive
uh we call them npis non-pharmaceutical
interventions like mask wearing and hand
hygiene and distancing
staying home or isolating if you're sick
we really
do expect them to have a positive
impact on flu rates this year however
you know again no one has a crystal ball
here and as you
said the people who say they have the
answers when they're looking
down the road generally don't we've
never been in this situation before
so i i think we have to recognize and
admit what we know and what we don't
know
but you can make some hypothetical
guesstimates and one of them of course
is that we may see
less flu but to be crystal clear there
is a big concern
in our health care system in this
country about
being inundated with two a highly
transmissible respiratory pathogens
you know at the same time and we just
have to wait and see how that pans out
mayor bowser you've been in office about
five years now has covet 19
been your biggest challenge thus far
for sure um i i would say
i i haven't met a single person who ever
imagined that we would have a
situation where we had to shut down our
whole city
um and deal with
a global health pandemic
and it is lasting a long time
and so dealing with that along with the
racial
reckoning that has is happening
in our country and especially in in
washington dc
kind of at the doorsteps of the capitol
we've been confronted
with a massive just
a massive response the public health
response
a public safety response and looking
towards a economic recovery
that's that's going to be very important
for us just to understand the swing of
what happened to us
just when covet hit we were preparing to
send our budget to the council
to our council for approval and we had
to
completely redo our budget because we
experienced at 800 million dollar
revenue decline
for this year for this fiscal year uh
and another 800 million for the next
fiscal year so we had to totally
uh rework our budget to to get those
things done
um we are in a better position than most
jurisdictions um however
um we were able to balance our budget
using reserves
um trimming some programs and still
investing in our priorities but we know
if this continues we won't
i'm able to continue that another thing
that's been highlighted by
covet is the great racial disparity and
how
covet um the covet fatalities and that
is
really borne out in washington dc where
we have
over 70 percent of our fatalities
related to covet are all
african-americans
and so really looking at the disparity
in health outcomes in our communities
has to take a front seat and we know
it's more than
insurance because most of our people are
insured
it has to do with access to specialists
in proper care but it also has to do
with some
disparities that we know exist in our
health care system um to start
and how we nationally and locally take
on
those those disparities
is going to make make us all resilient
but that's a long answer to your
question yes um this covet pandemic
and um the effects of it are by far
i think the the biggest challenge for
for any local leader
and as a leader in charge of guiding and
and trying to protect
citizens your biggest message right now
to to all of us
well my my biggest message is that we
have to continue to look out for each
other
and when the scientists told us that
staying at home and social distancing
and hand hygiene and staying home when
sick would work to blunt the curb
they were right about things um and so
we still have to continue to
follow the science and scientists and do
the things that are going to keep our
whole community
safe and that means sacrifice now
um for getting back to normal sooner
this has been absolutely informative and
enlightening and thank you all so very
much for joining us and for your
individual work
in trying to help fight this pandemic
on behalf of national geographic and
myself
i thank you so much panelists for being
here and to those of you at home
thank you for joining us i'm debra
roberts and if you want to learn more
about
national geographic's covet 19 coverage
you can go to the website
nat geo dot com slash coronavirus
[Music]
[Music]
you